allez on remonte le temps à présent avec
une personnalité des années 90 pendant
des années sur l'antenne de Fun Radio
celui que l'on surnommait le doc a
prodigué ses conseils santé et sexualité
à des millions dediteurs à 73 ans le
désormais retraité des ondes Christian
Spitz exerce comme médecin pédiatre il
vient d'ouvrir son cabinet à Salbris en
Loir-et-Cher
Ellen chapelet la rencontrer voilà voilà
est-ce que tu as des questions à me
poser jeune fille
son visage ne vous dit peut-être rien
mais il y a des milliers d'adolescents
dans les années 80-10 grâce à l'émission
radio Lovin fun le doc vient de
s'installer à Salbris le plus médiatique
des pédiatres exerce désormais trois
jours et demi par semaine dans un local
prêté par la mairie un soulagement pour
Aline sa fille de 5 ans n'avait pas
consulté de spécialistes depuis qu'elle
était bébé
c'est une très très bonne nouvelle et en
plus très gentil donc on est contentes
est-ce que vous connaissez son passé
alors de d'animateur radio et bien non
je l'ai appris je l'ai appris tout à
l'heure mais je trouve ça chouette
depuis la mi-juillet le docteur Spitz
exerce donc en Sologne à 10 minutes de
sa résidence principale même s'il
possède encore un cabinet à Paris il
découvre les avantages de la ville loin
du tumulte de la capitale
je suis ravi là après les consultations
je suis en Provin je fais la pause
déjeuner que je faisais pas à Paris
avec mon épouse je rentre à la maison on
va au resto et puis on fait une petite
pause et on reprend après j'ai envie de
continuer de travailler je suis en forme
tout va bien
avant la fin de l'année le pédiatre
devrait intégrer le futur centre de
santé qui est en cours d'aménagement
dans les locaux de cet ancien
supermarché 1000 mètres carrés avec à
terme une pharmacie et plusieurs
spécialistes
un médecin généraliste un pédiatre mais
également un gynécologue un
orthodontiste et un centre de radiologie
donc pour le moment nous sommes bien
dotés en espérance de spécialiste et
notre
souhait notre travail c'est de
convaincre des médecins généralistes de
rejoindre l'aventure aujourd'hui plus de
30% de la population vit dans un désert
médical avec des délais qui s'allongent
pour obtenir un rendez-vous une
situation qui n'est pas non plus
enviable du côté des praticiens
puisqu'il serait 45% en situation de
burn out